don't have a plan B like why have a plan
B because then you won't follow plan a
and I talk to them about that all the
time for you and I practicality grows as
you get older you have responsibilities
when you're this age it really doesn't
even make sense to do the things that we
grew up thinking we should tell our it
actually doesn't make sense if you think
about it to not try to do the most high
risk thing in your 20s they're of the
age where you could like all live
together in one tiny place they have no
rent in that scenario this is the age
where you can eat food for like two
bucks your body's like cool no problem
this is the eight when it's been a big
big Bastion of mine which is like we
have to get out of this like oh now
you're 22. you're a big boy now and you
should have a job 22 to 30 should be
when people take the busiest risks of
their lives they're not affecting
anybody else